you are kind of the OG cancel like you
got cancelled long before that was sort
of talked about I am kind of like the
poster boy for Council culture press got
involved pressured the homeless
Charities not to take my donations that
is the most journalist thing to do you
know what we're going to do the right
thing we're going to prevent a homeless
charity from getting money ex I didn't
really know how to handle it at the time
my management certainly didn't how do I
stop it and they suggested newsight and
uh that's how I ended up on newsight in
a turtleneck saying sorry
the worst thing was was the the apology
actually made it
worse hello mate hello it's great to
have you on the show and one of the
reasons is you are kind of the OG canc
like you got cancelled long before that
was sort of talked about and properly as
well and I also think there was kind of
no blueprint for how to deal with that
as well so you you you had to find your
own way through it we we'll talk about
all of that tell people a little bit
about what happened with you what you
were doing the comedy character all of
that uh yeah I am kind of like the
poster boy for Council culture I think
uh for many years as well after I got
cancelled anything to do with misogyny
or sexism it on my name would always fly
into that and uh it was difficult but um
yeah didn't we I didn't really know how
to handle it at the time my management
certainly didn't but uh to cut a long
story short I created a character uh
back in the day when there was Vine I
was one of the first social media um I I
wouldn't like to say influencers
comedians um I was doing the standup
comedy circuit and um I had a business
uh so I I I always used to create
alternative egos uh online different
characters um to sort of Shield me from
being out there cuz I I actually started
on the cruise ships doing cruise ship
comedy so it's like family friendly
stuff where you got to entertain the mom
the grandma and the kids at the same
time and when I come back to the UK I
realized the comedy clubs you know they
didn't like that you had to really push
it and then I really sort of exaggerated
that online and dapp offs was one of the
characters that I had created that was
sort of the main one on on Vine and it
was really an
exaggerated lad culture uh character and
uh he always lost he'd chase the birds
um you know he' you know try and pull
women and all that but he always ended
up the butt of the joke but it was all
done on my phone right so you know um
some people I think couldn't see
the difference between me and the
character even though it was outrageous
scripted sketch based comedy um and it
blew up and then I got a TV show on ITV
2 called app offs on the pool where we
taught men how to pull women with comedy
and then the world went mental about it
it was yeah it was and what was it that
actually triggered people going after
you because you you were doing live
shows to your audience and you said
something I I don't even remember what
it was I mean they call it a rape joke
they said it was a rape joke but what it
was that's that whole situation was it
was like a um a melting pop it was like
bubbling cuz I was arguing with
journalists for a long time on the lead
up to that stuff had happened where I
bought out like a Christmas album and i'
made jokes in there about homeless
people but we were raising money for the
homeless and the Press got involved
pressured the homeless Charities not to
take my donations so that was like the
first thing that was the first thing I
sort of yeah I know that is the most
journalist thing to do you know what
we're going to do the right thing we're
going to prevent a homeless charity from
getting money ex yeah it was because
yeah it was it was the craziest thing
it's because I'd used the word [__] in
there and you got to remember this is
like 15 10 10 or 11 years ago you know I
was y I was a lot younger a lot less
what I'd say educated and I didn't
really care about the language I used I
was all just about the comedy and you
know I didn't realize how sensitive the
world was and stuff like that and um you
found out though I found out quick yeah
I found out quick um but I couldn't get
my head around that and that was like a
Tipping Point for me cuz I was like look
I've raised a lot of money here and they
they they they they used um the the
charity actually ended up using it for
his marketing campaign you know we won't
accept money from the likes of these
people and I I was I went you know back
on social media and I was like imagine
if I was walking around handing money
out you know and making jokes would they
they not take they wouldn't care they
just want the money they want the you
know um and I couldn't get my around it
and I argued then my Vines were getting
bought up and lots of different things
but the actual night that sealed the
deal for me and ended it all I was doing
a show just before I went on I think it
was The Huffington Post or something
like that had done a piece calling my TV
show in almanac for rape culture because
I was basically giving men a makeover
and then taking them out and teaching
them how to chat up girls with jokes and
stuff like that and then they were
talking to women you know um well that's
the same as rape mate yeah well do you
know what I mean but I thought I thought
he was giving men confidence I mean
you're the new Ted Bundy down you know
what I mean yeah crack a joke now get
him um but yeah and I was angry about it
I really was my family has been um
affected by sexual violence right so
actually in our family we have had uh
horrible situations like that and I got
a backlash from my friends and family
because because of this article and it
was the first time it really hit home to
me you know what they were saying that I
was Pro rape in this article and um and
I lost my [__] and I went out on stage
and um I I was venting uh and I said um
you know if I wanted to make a TV show
that was an almanac for rape if I wanted
to teach Mentor r I wouldn't have
written 6 30 minute episodes I just
would have done one one minute episode
and said go down the road get some duct
tape you know and I and that's how I was
painting it I was like if I wanted to do
that that's what I would have done you
know poking front of the journalist and
then a woman at the front had said uh
well my friend Susie or whatever she
loves you she's gagging for a rape and I
went there you go she's gagging for a
rape and what they done is they got they
got the clip but but it was Sinister
because when they got the clip they
clipped it so I went you know what you
want to do go down the road get some
duct tape she's gagging for a rape and
then bang was out no context at all is
that what happened that that was
circulated on the Internet by all of the
Publications so your metros and all of
that and you know by Within 3 days there
was 60,000 people signed a petition to
get the pro rape comedian off itv2 and
that was the beginning of the end
[__] that was the level of
misrepresent Cu I didn't know any it was
horrific it was hor but look and I've
battled uh with my cuz been on a mad
journey through my sobriety you know
because that turned me into an alcoholic
and a and a drug addict and you know I
lost my mind I was suicidal it was it
was crazy but I've been on this mad
Journey where I've looked back and I've
gone you have to take some
responsibility you know for this the
silly things you've said in order to
heal from it so I went through a phase
of like really believing that you know
maybe there was some malice and it
wasn't until I really got sober which is
only been the last year where I looked
back and I was like look you may have
been a bit of a [__] but there was no
malice in that you know forgive yourself
and you know you you you became you know
I had millions of followers and you know
maybe some of the stuff I was saying was
a bit much now having daughters I look
at it differently but yeah Jesus it was
a hatchet job and so the the video came
out it obviously went viral and then
what
happened um well my manager called me in
and said um they're they're now cuz I
had a tour uh which I've been paid a
massive advance for big UK tour yeah and
my manager came in and said um right the
the the Press uh the journalists are now
targeting the venues saying sending you
know so the actual journalists were
tweeting the venues saying have you seen
our piece on the pro rape comedian
that's coming to your tour so my manager
we had a lot of Crisis meeting they were
like the the the the the venues are
dropping right so the tour is getting
cancelled so that was the next big hit
you know the money that you have have
earned from this has got to go back and
you might even get sued uh which I did
actually end up getting doing I got
there's a lot of financial implications
to the commitments I've made because of
what that they considered was my
behavior at one of my gigs so that was
the first thing the tour was scrapped
the tour was cancelled uh TV show was
scrapped then my management uh then the
Press were contacting the other artists
on the roster so the other the other
talent and putting pressure on them do
you want to really be on a roster with
the pro rape guy so then the management
said sorry mate our talent is saying
they're going to leave if you don't
leave so you're fir so then my
management dropped me um and then um my
dad died within within a short amount of
time I think a matter of weeks he
randomly passed away and then that was
really like a big rock bottom for me and
I said and the Press I couldn't stop the
Press they were like everywhere and um I
asked my management just before they'
sort of let me go how do I stop it and
they suggested newsight go on newsight
and apologize and uh that's how I ended
up on newsight in a turtleneck saying
sorry which you will do when you're
about to kill yourself yeah isn't it
really interesting Dan that the complete
lack of empathy that people had when you
were facing Financial ruin yeah your
father had just passed away and it
didn't matter because they were still
coming in yeah and they were still
trying to eviscerate and Destroy every
semblance of your career yeah the worst
the worst thing was was the the apology
actually made it worse the that I
finally realized that they don't want an
apology they want you to die or they
want you to go and I I couldn't compreh
I could what I thought to cuz I am
extremely motivated and I believe
creatively I'm talented and I thought
this is going to be really bad but I'll
come back from it and I'll I'll create
again and I'll I'll build it back up
again but I realized very soon that you
know I'd made a mistake to them that was
so bad that I was never allowed to be a
comedian again and never allowed to
perform never allowed to have an
audience NE never it doesn't matter what
they just don't want me here to to see
me and that that was when I was like
well what else do I have you know it was
it was a strange it was like that it
happened as well that was what I was
alluding to when I said there was no uh
kind of nobody knew how to deal with it
because if that were to happen now
there's 53 different ways you could deal
with it that probably would be to your
advantage in the current climate cuz you
just do a video show how they
misrepresented what happened and then
loads of people would come out on your
side and you'd carry on Etc but back
then I also think it's probably the case
that the media had way more power than
they do now right would that be fair to
say do you think yeah and I think 100%
And I also think that the public are
wise to it uh I think I think like
before the clickbait they didn't know it
was clickbait you know so so like say
for instance like I was I was doing gigs
say for instance there was one up in
Glasgow that they managed to get
canceled quite early on and they simply
just had an article that said Pro rape
comedian coming to Glasgow right and you
had to click on it to go through to
actually see the context of what i' done
but who clicks on articles not a lot of
people right so I could see all the
comments going ain't even reading it
don't want him
here now people are I think a little bit
more intelligent to how the media behave
and also after we've had the deaths of
people you know like Caroline Flack and
other people you know where the media
basically killed them or or or pushed
them into killing themselves if if the
if the talent pushes back a little bit
especially with mental health they they
ease off like Philip scoffield but to me
but to me I was to me I was just at the
bottom of a packet of cocaine and in a
pub do you know what I mean I was just
like if I hide for long enough maybe
when i' come back up they'll be gone but
it it didn't end it didn't stop for
years years you know what I find really
hypocritical about all this is that
Frankie boy has been doing rape jokes
since God knows when yeah they're
they're online you can go and see them
doesn't affect him no one says he's a
pro rape comedian but you yeah again it
wasn't until I sobered up that I'd look
back on this and and I could look at it
from an educated point of view I think
that what comes into it especially the
difference maybe with people like
Frankie Bo and Jimmy
Carr I I initially thought maybe it's
classism do you know what I mean maybe
maybe the the way that the journal or
the way that the industry is look he
he's dangerous he's not intelligent
enough to be being ironic do you know
what I mean whereas Jimmy Carr we know
he's educated he doesn't mean it it's a
joke right um but then my I think it's
got It's got to do with uh social media
following you know I was one of the
first to a million on Facebook a million
on Snapchat I was growing and I think
that they get intimidated especially the
big newspaper Publications and people in
charge I think they get intimidated by
your influence yeah and I think there's
also probably a a an element of like
there's a difference between a character
uh and a comedian telling jokes and I
think frankly a lot of people in the
media don't understand comedy so they
don't understand that it's possible and
I I've come up with like I remember
doing this thing when Jerry switz's K
got canceled in Edinburgh yeah um doing
a thing for the BBC it's on our Channel
where the guy goes well but isn't the
opinions that this guy expressed aren't
they terrible and I was going it's a
[__] character like they're not the
opinions of this person he's it's like
MCB
you don't go and see MTH and go oh my
God someone stabbed someone it's a show
yeah but yeah I mean look around the
same sort of time or not just or or or
maybe not too far after was the age of
Ali G you know and Ali G was on channel
4 walking out underneath a big woman's
batty you know coming out and doing all
these sexual innuendos but you know
again he's a highly educated um well
spoken you know I don't know what it is
I I was a workingclass lad off a council
state playing a workingclass lad yes you
know but look it's maybe I should have
been a little bit more intelligent If I
Could Turn Back Time now I would have
gone on newsight as a character like as
as like a Oxford educated oh yeah you
know it was just the whole thing was
just an idea to you know it was just you
know just go on there really Posh and
really emphasize highlight the problems
of the exactly yes I was here to
highlight lad culture and the problems
with it you all fell for it but but
unfortunately I was emotionally
destroyed by that point yeah yeah and I
that was the thing that cuz I was
looking back at that interview and you
emotionally destroyed really Nails it
you look like a human being who was
suffering deeply suffering yeah well I
was I was suicidal and you know I was I
I didn't realize it then but I was also
right in the grips of addiction um a lot
of lads out there will go through a
similar thing in life where you know
they they play with drink and drugs on a
social on a social playing field you
know on a social landscape you know at
weekends and stuff like that and then
when things get a little bit tricky for
them in Life or they're stress it starts
off with you know heavy week at work I I
need to get smashed heavy week at work
you know what a misses to do my head I
need to get smashed and when you start
leaning towards Like Cocaine especially
as a way to cope with life when big [__]
happens to you your coping mechanism
destroys you I mean it was the first
time I looked myself away and drank and
used and um it really wasn't the right
time for me to be on TV but I I wanted
to stem you know the the onslaught from
the media and that's such a profound
point because I think as blogs
particularly the type of background that
we're from where you know you talk you
know you've got to and look there's
there's also something to be said you've
just got to crack on keep going I
believe in that but also that culture
where it goes well you go out you get
hammered you know and yeah forget about
it mate just have a few beers you'll be
all right yeah eventually if you keep
doing that it it will ruin you W yeah it
did it did it's um yeah it's it's scary
the the power that they have over people
in the industry now and I know for a
fact that majority of comedians that are
out there they're not they can't express
themselves fully um in the fear of you
know to me you know when you look at
Fame and following and you know
notoriety and you know when you start
making your way up you want to grab hold
of it you know so hard to get it's so
hard to get anywhere in the industry and
you want to grab hold of it and the way
that they can just go and snatch it from
you is terrifying it is how did you know
you had a problem because you know we've
all had a big sesh we've all had a you
know we've gone out a bit too much
there's also been times where we've
overindulged for a prolonged period of
time but how did you know that this was
a real problem well I didn't for up
until probably about a year and a half
ago I I was still sort of battling with
the idea that you know I deserved it and
it was just the way I coped with life um
but I realized I had a problem when I
tried to stop um and look I couldn't see
that it was destroying things at home
for me because my in this industry um
that we work in a lot of people love a
drink and everything else and um I used
to use that as a bit as a bit of an
excuse if I was doing a show D I'd be
out and doing it and it took me away
from my family and then the comedowns
and the hangovers um were disastrous for
having a young family two little baby
girls got two little beautiful girls and
and a northern wife which don't put up
with no sh you know what I mean so it
was the calm downs and the hangovers
were hell you know I just be handing the
kids iPads and you know and it caused a
lot of friction with me and the me and
the wife um we only recently got married
last year and shortly after that we we
broke up um because I was just losing my
mind you know going out on heavy
sessions coming back and she was arguing
and saying look at you you know why are
you still doing this d d d and I was
like why you ruining my [__] fun
nearly 40 years old still on it and I
thought right I got to stop and then
tried to stop and realized that I
couldn't cope with life without without
a [__] you button you know I needed a
button to you know it was everything was
too much for me you know the the the the
the guilt and shame of the past or you
know dealing with dealing with whatever
life was throwing at me in this stress I
had no other way of um I hadn't worked
out other ways to cope with life so I
kept pressing the button even though I
said I was going to stop and I didn't
want to and then it dawned me I'm an
addict you know I'd I'd become addicted
to to that to and what were the triggers
for you what was the moment that you
went you know what screw this I'm off
I'm off on a sesh I'm off to get wrecked
Mike my triggers could be anything from
the it's the same as all the other Lads
out there that are in the M midst of it
could be anything from a bank holiday
weekend yeah you know the sun being out
you know what I mean it's just like the
sun would be out life is tough the sun
is out you know a bit of a stressful
week but to to be honest with you I
could rarely drink you know I could I
could go out and drink depending on the
company and not get on uh anything else
but um rarely you know I'd get four five
drinks in I'd be like let's just go
[__] mental what I realize now
through all the work I've done on my
sobriety and my podcast and all that is
the um the pure escapism is what I was
addicted to the the the Oblivion right
like I just I could never cope with
being myself and I think that's part of
the reason why I've spent my whole
working career creating characters Jim
and Steve kid Frankie all of these
different characters and losing myself
in that is sitting with myself and being
with myself for too long became really
awkward and normally towards the end of
the week I was waiting for an excuse
trying to cause an argument or some just
to get out get to the pub and and seek
Oblivion we'll get you back to the
interview in a minute but first that my
friends is a sound of another sale on
Shopify the all-in-one Commerce platform
to start run and grow your business I
know that bill building a business takes
work look at my face I'm exhausted but
the lovely thing about Shopify is that
no matter how big you want to grow
Shopify is with you every step of the
way Shopify is the Commerce platform
revolutionizing millions of businesses
worldwide whether you're selling
handmade jewelry art prints or podcast
merch Like Us by our merch Shopify
simplify selling online and in person so
you can successfully grow your business
Shopify even gets you selling across
social media marketplaces like Facebook
Instagram and Tik Tok Tik Tok just makes
me angry I'm too old so if you're ready
to get serious about selling sign up for
A1 per month troll period at shopify.com
[Music]
trigger and now back to the
interview and how how did you get
through it how did you overcome it um
well firstly like anyone that's been um
sober or through a program or anything
like that I had to go I had to go away
take myself away to like a rehab um but
I mean I had to h a rock bottom first
I'd had many um you know after my father
had passed away I considered suicide one
evening and luckily spoke to the
Samaritans I still didn't even think I
had a problem cuz was I was on the drugs
and everything and um it was weird cuz
I'd broken up with my Ms then and moved
into my drug dealer's house which I
thought was a good
idea he had a spare room and drugs so um
but he just got brand new white carpet
business was good for obviously he had a
brand new white carpet and I laugh about
it but I was thinking about cutting my
wrists and uh the and I was like I don't
want to [__] his carpet up and that's
why that's that was like that stopped me
for a while and then I was like thinking
of other ways and then I was like you're
thinking about
committing suicide mate you're [__]
something's wrong with you so I couldn't
speak to me Mom couldn't speak to you
know I broke up with my M weren't going
to tell my mates and rang the Samaritans
and that was the first time that I
realized my mental health was screwed
but I and I'm I bounced up from there
but still could associate with the drink
and drugs but my my my wife had to have
had enough of it and we were away in
Mara at a film premere and I just we'd
had a massive Fallout the day before and
we were going to my Bayer and she said
just don't drink when we're there start
do drugs I was like look I want to do
drugs but I got a drink we're in my bay
and then once I started drinking the
other thing happened she flew back and
and she was like don't just don't come
home you know and then I was like what
about the kids you know I mean I stayed
there for days like Burying my head in
the sand drinking and whatever and then
by the time I got back my
life you know I couldn't go home and and
then I suddenly I was sobering up going
who the [__] is this guy what like what
is it and that was that was my rock
bottom I had to save the one the only
thing that means the well to me which
was my family so I took myself away and
then day by day by day just didn't drink
and didn't didn't use and really focused
on identifying triggers and the big
change for me and anyone out there
that's struggling I think is and this is
why I'm so deep into mindset now and
which is the key and it's helped me so
much with everything is realizing the
the changing point for me is realizing
that the voice in our head isn't us so
the thoughts in our
head that we don't have to follow the
thoughts in our head so when i' be like
I need to drink or I'm missing out or
that's too stressful I can't handle it
I'd be like who is that because that
ain't me yeah you know and I could
decide whether or not and I could see it
as a trigger and then working on on that
narrative and then I realized that in
order to overcome the voice I had to
build meal mental resilience so I
started boxing and you know tried to
channel my addictive personality into
positive addictions doing the cold water
dips just anything I saw online that I
saw people doing that was hard to do
that I had to use my my my mental
resilience to continue to do and uh and
then the voice just became easier and
easier to ignore until my life turned
into sobriety so interesting you say
that because I know about me that I have
an addictive personality I've never been
addicted to like drugs or alcohol or
anything like that and I realized um
that I have an addictive personality and
I just have to get addicted to the right
things yeah uh I remember one time a
friend of mine when I was 18 took me to
a casino and I remember just he he gave
me this chip that was like a 100 quid or
something and I remember just looking at
it in my hand thinking this does not
feel like1 yeah and if I get into this
it's not going to end well yeah and so
I've always just made sure that I it's
like like you say not not getting
addicted to the wrong thing but you're
still going to be addicted to something
so you just got to find the right thing
to get addicted to 100% I think we're
just we we're dopamine Chasers you know
whether it's on your phone whether it's
in in the gym whether it's porn U
gambling sex drugs whatever you know we
are going to chase dopamine those little
Sparks so you got picked the right Pi
the right one thing that's really
interesting about your story I think
particularly bringing you know the
sobriety and what happened with your
comedy character together is you I
imagine particularly when you're
drinking taking drugs you've got a lot
of guilt you've got a lot of Shame Etc
and you're probably thinking well I I
you know I deserve to be cancelled I did
things wrong but then it's interesting
to me because I think on reflection and
as I hear your story I've never really
delv that deep into it I don't know that
you did do anything wrong exactly do you
know what I mean it's difficult because
I believe that now I believe now that
some of the stuff I did was
irresponsible you know with a big
platform right what I I think like you
know some of the jokes some of the vines
I did although I still find it's such a
conundrum because I still find them
funny yeah you know like I'll give you
an example one of the one of the one of
the vines I did where I was uh uh
obviously it's it's an actress you know
someone else that's in the industry and
I'm like I'm do pretending but I'm as
Dapper I walk up with the phone I'm like
all right sweetheart can I smell your
fanny and she's like no you can't I'm
like well it must be your [__] feet
then right it's just a gag right so I'd
always just try and find them gags those
written gags and then put them in throw
away but then when you got millions of
this is the This is the part when you
got millions of followers and there's a
lot of lads out there emulating what you
do you know now that I've got daughters
I look at and like what do I really want
Lads walking around with their phon you
know because people are stupid right so
so I'm always split i i i half believe
you anything goes in comedy as long as
there's not malice but then I also
believe that if you've got a big
following you've got a responsibility to
put the correct message out so I'm I'm
stuck but where I'm at now through my
sobriety is I know for a fact that there
was no malice involved in the rape joke
and the rape comment and the level of
cancellation and the hatchet job uh I'm
at peace with whereas over the last up
like I say up until about a year ago
over the last nine years I beat myself
up about it I couldn't live with myself
you know what I'd put myself through
what I'd lost what could have been and
um and that's why I hid in in Oblivion
do you know what I mean so it's a tricky
one but sobriety has given me the
foresight to sort of look at it and go
well you wouldn't be here talking about
it unless you know you've got a great
story so you made it to trigonometry
yeah you know what I mean so anyone out
there rap
jokes but do you think part of the
problem as well is those that type of
humor you'd hear on the building site
those are the type of like I used to
work in a working man's club in South
London that's why when I when I left
school that's what I did when I wasn't
at Uni yeah and I see I hear that I and
that that is just Lads that I grew up
with that is the type of humor that we
had and we would see No Malice in it
because it was part of our culture like
when someone comes in you know he was a
mate or whatever else you would rip him
you would take the piss you'd be harsh
that that's how we are that's how we
were brought up that's how you express
love or whatever else and other people
would see it who are not from that
culture who are from a middle class and
they'd be midd you know they'd be
offended like well why are you taking
the piss out of this why are you taking
the piss out of that that's that's a
good point and we go well it's not
because I I think you're anything less
because you get your teeth done or
whatever else but that's just what we do
yeah and that's the moral dilemma that I
face because and and I made mistakes you
know because if you imagine I had 5
million followers across I mean and I'm
talking back in 10 years ago so like as
as currency goes that's like you know
that's like your ksis now but I had 5
million followers uh over here right and
then I had 60,000 people that signed a
petition over here and a handful of
journalists and a load of people that
are never going to come to a comedy gig
that are never going to watch my TV show
The canceling me and I turned my back on
the 5 million and said sorry I'm sorry
actually you're right you L are right
I'm very sorry these lot and me and this
this lot and all these Lads that didn't
have someone out there that were you
know communicating they they all felt
left let down and and they were vocal
about that oh did did your audience have
a go you for apologizing they were upset
about that yeah cuz for years after that
and I and honestly I mean three or four
years every time I posted a video it was
rape rapist Pro rape rape misogynist
sexist and then my actual audience
snowflake [__] uh you your dead you
know you and you know whatever you know
has been you should never have
apologized turtleneck wanker I was just
like I was just like that one is hard to
yeah in the end I had to I had to I had
to go with it and take the piss out of
myself you know and and admit and hold
my hands up and be like yeah I was
beaten up man I was beaten up yeah yeah
it's and it's also as well the regret
and I I think that we're not kind to
ourselves because we don't talk about
the physical reaction that we get from
things like cancellation from anxiety
when I get anxious or I get like I'm you
know I have a you know every day of my
life is basically me doing everything I
can because I've got I I I can go to
depression I can go to to addiction I
can that's in me I know that and every
day I work so that Beast that on the
shoulder is where it
is but we forget that when we when we
feel anxiety or depression it's not just
mental it hits your body yeah it can
kill you it can damage you yeah and you
your body reacts and you're thinking to
yourself why is my body reacting like
this in a physical way so you're looking
back at yourself going oh why didn't I
do this or why didn't I do that but your
body was also doing stuff that you were
probably thinking to yourself what's
happening I was yeah I H yeah it's I got
PTSD from it I must have because like
even when tiny little things kick off
like I I said to you before we started I
terrified of using my Twitter when tiny
little things kick off or trolls kick
off and stuff like that I do get that
that anxiety straight away and um I try
to be as creatively free as I can um and
I admire people that just don't give a
[__] but we didn't have Ricky Javas uh
back then saying I'll never apologize
for a joke and we didn't have you know
your Steven fry we didn't have all these
people going you know I don't give
offense you take it and all of these all
of these great voices that were talking
about people you know at the time it
happened I believed i' had been a
terrible person and and and I'd been
correctly punished for it you know it
wasn't until I stopped taking drugs and
drinking that I realized well [__] me
you L done a number and I'm curious what
you make of it because one of the things
you know um I think like loyalty
especially to people who who've
benefited from your success uh or people
who sorry loyalty to people that uh have
supported you or have helped you in some
way is really important right and I
imagine it would have been very
difficult to have your manager drop you
right in the middle of all of this
instead of like fighting it with you in
some way or guiding you through it I
imagine that would have been difficult
as well because you're kind of you don't
have anyone in your in your corner
anymore yeah cuz I was kind of plucked
out of you know I was a comedian but
also I had my own business and I was
working and you know what was your
business in then I was uh an estate
agency MH so you know I was doing comedy
I went away and done comedy and come
back for a bit of money and then you
know I I didn't think comedy was going
to work for me so I was building a
business and um you know this this
management company come going look at
your numbers you know and pluck me out
of that life and sort of said look come
with us we're going to do all of these
personal appearances so I started making
loads of money going to nightclubs and
meeting the fans and that then I was
doing tours then they got me a TV show
and that so you know I'd left my old
life behind and my old friends really
and um you know and I was like you know
I was like making money and you know and
then it was like boom yeah thanks but
[__] off a little bit and it was yeah it
was very embarrassing but also yeah
quite lonely but yeah I didn't really
the only thing I knew to do back then
was Escape so yeah no no totally and you
mentioned friends that's something I was
going to ask you about sobriety as well
because I imagine that when you are
someone who drinks a lot and takes drugs
a lot you're surrounded by people who do
the same and that I imagine makes it
harder to change because you're not
having to just let go of the Habit
you're having to go let go of a whole
social environment that you've created
for yourself yeah it's it's I think it's
one of the main reasons why people
struggle to to get sober and to overcome
addiction because unfortunately our
culture our culture looks or us as a
people we look at addiction as somebody
that wakes up and leans for a bottle of
oore that's on a park bench you know
that's what we think addiction looks
like but to me I didn't drink Monday
Tuesday Wednesday I was recovering and
then Thursday Thursday Friday I was
drinking and then Saturday I was on the
packet right and then I was [__] again
but for the last 20 years I was either
drunk or hung over you and so and I
learned very quickly that our bodies Our
Minds when we're not at base level when
we're when we're consuming drink and
drugs and we're just underneath our
minds are going what's the [__]
problem so you focus on everything else
you know the mes is doing my heading
this is doing my heading and it turns
you quite even but what I found with my
friends is is that you know if you're
saying to them that you're an addict and
you've got a problem but but they're
doing exactly the same as you if not
worse then it's like you're almost
calling them an addict and you're
holding a mirror up and my friends don't
like a mirror held up to him unless it's
covered in cocaine trust me they like
they were like what do you mean you got
a problem mate you're a [__]
lightweight do you know what I mean so
and we're all growing up all got
families all got young kids and then
especially if you express why it it you
know fr shade on them so I lost a I say
lost they're still there if I want to
talk to them but they they don't ring me
because the only thing we had in common
was drinking and doing drugs so it's
hard it is hard you got you you mourn
you mourn your old old life when you
truly accept that you can no longer
drink and do drugs you're you're
mourning your old life yeah and that is
such a profound Point Dan I remember
when like cuz I was I use booze cuz deep
down I'm quite a shy person I'm quite
sensitive I'm not so I developed this
kind of you know taking the piss quick
wited whatever else in order to cover it
and the reason I started smoking is cuz
back then you could smoke in pubs is
that if the conversation got awkward you
put a [__] in your mouth and then what it
you start you start smoking the reason I
started drinking was the same it was a
way to cope with anxiety and then it
gave me confidence so I could be bit
more jacked the lad taking the piss
banter banter banter banter banter the
moment I took those Comfort blankets
away all that was left was Francis and
then suddenly I realized oh I've got a
whole load of stuff that I need to deal
with which is a lifetime of work let's
be honest but I always remember telling
one of my mates I went to him Pete you
know I've I've given up drink mate I
can't do it it's it's it's it's
destroying my
life and um I remember him saying to me
after a while he goes you know I'm in
Francis ever since you've given up the
booze mate you're not as much fun oh
I've had that yeah that that was like
I've had that that was right there that
was a little knife and I was like I it
is hard and it's what pulled me back in
last time cuz I had a stint of sobriety
before you know but i' done it for my
misses I was like you know okay I ain't
got a problem I'll stop and then
Christmas was coming my mates were like
come on man and I was like all right
I'll just go back to the occasional piss
up and like it but it accelerated so
fast but I'd advise I think to all men
out there one of the biggest problems
that we've got especially with like male
suicide and men's mental health and
stuff like that is the fact that men we
don't know who we are because we've got
so many different hats that we've got to
wear right we're dads or we're workers
you know we got to work we got to earn
or we're Partners husbands but who are
you right because when you're not that
and you're with your mates and you're
drinking but who are you like and that's
sobriety to me was like right so I can't
escape this [__] right I've got a
[__] so the first part of sobriety
you're like oh [__] I did that I did
that I did that I did that and normally
if anything would pop up you know like I
drank at my wedding and it and it breaks
my it's one of my biggest regrets now
cuz there's a certain part of my wedding
that I can't remember and I caused a lot
of problems and when I started thinking
about that at the beginning of my
sobriety I desperately wanted to [__]
Escape them feelings but then I sat with
it and I got through it and I understood
it and I looked back at the reasons why
and then other things started popping up
oh remember when you've done that
remember when you've done that and
slowly the first [__] four or five or
six months was it was like oh my God I
hate myself and I can't escape it but
through all the work that you do you
slowly start putting it all to bed and
then everything sort of calms down and
you sort of go oh man so I'm this guy
that actually overcome that and I've
sorted that out and you start getting an
idea of who you are and I just recommend
it to men so much just stop doing
whatever you do to escape being yourself
to find out who you are and you talk
about the work what do you mean by the
work then so the work is managing
managing my thoughts not escaping
negative thoughts you know dealing with
them and also not so the work to me in
life in general first of all is building
um my mental resilience right so you saw
that I boxed the other day um boxing for
me is is is one of the best ways to do
it because one and okay so you knock out
50y old so that [__] yeah that makes you
feel good you know what I mean I'm not
ages anyone can have it
um equal that's what I learned from
getting cancelled everyone is equal so
I'll smash anyone
um no but boxing so it's all about doing
things it's nice and simple it's all
about doing things that I don't want to
do for long-term gratification instead
of short-term it's like the opposite of
drugs yeah so drugs is instantly gra you
know instantly happy in instantly
achieved my goal um and I had to rewire
my mind so put yourself in positions
that I don't want to be in so first of
all I box at 5:30 in the morning so I
have to get up at 4:30 so the first
every single day six days a week um so I
get up 4:30 in the morning that's the
first thing I don't want to do it and
I've overcome that and then boxing the
training is horrible it's grueling and
that's bad but what's even worse is the
sparring three times a week so you know
you got to fight so every time you step
through the the ropes you're doing
something that your mind is telling you
not to do and to me that work constantly
overcoming fear and all of that stuff
makes not drinking and not taking drugs
and not being a [__] a piece of piss M
you know what I mean and also it tells
me that the actual real me is strong
yeah is really strong you know and my
mind and now my negative thought Loops
like take jealousy for instance or any
other things that pop into us as men's
minds and can consume us and turn into
turn into negative behavior I can see it
now like whereas before the thought
became the feeling but now the th
doesn't become the feeling the th
as it's trying to turn into the feeling
gets taken and thrown away and it just
feels powerful I'll get you back to Dan
in the minute but first let me recommend
a product that we use all day every day
here at trigonometry Towers look going
online without Express VPN is like using
your smartphone without a protective
case most of the time you'll probably be
fine but all it takes is one accidental
drop onto solid concrete to make you
wish you'd protected yourself every
every time you connect to an unencrypted
Network in cafes hotels airports or
anywhere else anyone on the same network
can gain access to your data I'm talking
your passwords Financial details the law
hackers can make up to $1,000 per person
selling personal info on the dark web
don't let that be you and it doesn't
take much technical knowledge to hack
someone a smart 12-year-old could do it
a grand why am I not doing that I said a
smart 12-year-old anyway expressvpn
helps to keep you safe by creating a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet so that hackers
can't steal your sensitive data it's
super secure it' take a hacker with a
supercomputer over a billion years to
get past expressvpn's encryption secure
your online data today and get 3 months
for free by visiting
expressvpn.com
trigger that's e x p r e SS
vpn.com /t trigger and get an extra 3
months free now back to the
show so interesting what you said about
playing long-term games because this is
the thing I always say to the young guys
who work here is like all life is is one
big marshmallow test you know that the
marshmallow test is the E the the
strongest predictor I mean people keep
saying it's been debunked and whatever
but it is actually just like in reality
objectively true whether that particular
experiment was welld designed or not but
basically the strongest predictor with
kids of Lifetime success is this if you
give a kid a marshmallow um and you say
you can have it now in which case that's
all you're getting or if you hold on to
this for like 30 seconds or a minute or
five minutes or whatever that time is
I'll give you a second marshmallow the
kids that will wait for the second
marshmallow Su they're going to be
successful and the ones that have it
right then and then they're not going to
be as successful and that's all life is
if you play short-term games whether
it's drugs whether it's whatever you're
going to get short-term results you're
going to get the dopamine hit right now
but it's not the same as getting the
dopamine hit of building a great body or
a great business or whatever it is that
you're actually going to take time to do
the satisfaction of taking the time to
Bear the discomfort for a year two years
five 10 years whatever the payoff then
is so different is so much bigger yeah
and just for hearing from hearing that
test for the first time what I took from
that as well is the period of time where
the child has got to wait even
anticipating the wait and they have to
sit with themselves and their thoughts
yeah is the key you know if you're
confident enough to be able to sit with
your thoughts and hold back for the
greater good then um then yeah and
through sobriety and all of this stuff
it sent me down a road where I'm like
well I really want to find out I I
really want to work out what else is
negative you know look so I started
looking into like the ego you know and
how I was responding to you know and I
just went on this and I advise it to any
man out there just sit with yourself
without escaping and try and work out
what the problem is and the challenge is
as well I think it's even more difficult
now because of social media because
we're surrounded by things that give
instant gratification and turn us into
dopamine monsters dopamine things yeah
yeah I mean for me as well like when you
I mean you guys will know this as well
when you when you you know do do I want
to create great content like
thought-provoking content or do I want
likes or you know what I mean I went
down the phase of really hijacking like
news stories and then coming up with you
know I went through a little phase where
like you know all the trans transgender
stuff and d d and I was like yeah we'd
never talk
about you know but for me you got to
keep the women audience happy the female
audience wants their trans
episode every day it's you know but
again like the ego I know what you mean
yeah the ego can send you send you on
Roots you know but when you're
passionate truly passionate about
something um it's just the content so
much better you know what I mean so I'm
working I'm still working all of this
stuff out but it's great you got to be
authentic to what you truly believe
exactly exactly otherwise but and the
reason you know what it's not true from
a pure success point of view because
like you say if you tap into whatever is
heart right this second and you do your
thing about that it's going to get the
likes it's going to get the shares it's
going to get the views and that's true
in all sorts of other areas of life the
problem is you never truly feel happy or
successful with that success because
it's not been earned in a way that's
authentic to you so it's not you that's
successful it's this fake persona you've
created that's exactly it and also we
can sometimes jump at it so quickly that
we express other people's views that we
know are popular on those subjects and
that's something that I'm desperately
trying to Veer away from because I truly
believe I I don't see my followers as
followers I see my followers like a
follower like a one person like my
audience is one person that would go hm
hold on a second do you really think
that or is it popular you know and and I
don't want to cheat that person and also
if I'm going to divide opinion or be
disliked I want to [__] I don't want
to do what I did before and [__] myself
I want to go hold on to it and go no I
[__] mean that and if you don't like
it then [__] off yeah you know which
which is a tough one for me to get to
and it only comes through authenticity
it does have have you done therapy Dan
have you yeah a lot I yeah I actually
started back in the day uh with anger
management therapy but it pissed me off
honestly it's so weird honestly the guy
you'd think that they'd teach the
[__] the the the psychologists or
whatever to not be so [__] annoying
when it's like anger management I can
see why you needed anger management yeah
that was years ago though again before I
thought I had a problem you know and he
asked I can remember he asked me he said
to me you know do you do do do drugs and
I was like yeah I'll do a bit of cocaine
and he come up with this analogy where
he was like and he was like this public
school boy and he was like oh I was at
the Henley rata and I was I was sat with
with a bowl with a with a cereal bowl of
cocaine just spooning it into my nose
and I was like shut the [__] up there's
no way one you'd be able to afford all
of that cocaine and no one would you
know and then he just said he threw it
in the river and I was like oh my God
and he lost me you know what I mean so I
couldn't connect with him you don't
treat cocaine like that have a bit of
respect yeah exactly at least bag it up
and sell it or give it to someone but no
but I couldn't relate to him at all and
uh on my last on my second to last
session of it I didn't think I had anger
management problems at the time but I I
clearly did I was coming back from a gig
actually at at my um Comedy Club it
wasn't mine then before I bought it you
were there you were there the other day
yeah I was coming back from a gig from
clap North to clap South and I got in
this cab and I'd been on the Charlie and
all of that stuff and I was arguing with
my friend about who was going to pay for
the cab and we didn't know but the cab
driver had taken a detour to like um
battery right and I I suddenly realized
and this was like I had my Ang last
anger management U thing on the NHS like
the next day and I thought where's he
taking us and then it's cuz I was my
paranoid cocaine delusion I thought
maybe he's taken us to a secret place
where all the taxi drivers where they
take people that don't pay the fairs and
all the taxi drivers are going to
[__] you know beat us up it's like a
secret taxi Fight Club yeah so I'm going
no let me out let me out and he pulled
up at this building and got out and I
had a big bag of stellers and I smashed
the window and climbed out and chased
him into this building and punched him
and it was [__] battery police
station he' run into so I got nicked and
that's that was the that was just before
I was about to finish my um I say
punched him I kind of like went to hit
him the guy jumped over the thing and I
got arrested and um that was like right
you seriously you know you know I didn't
even stop doing drugs then for years you
were really dedicated mate yeah that was
crazy yeah but listen it's I mean the
one thing that I'm really hearing out of
this is I know this is a weird thing to
say but this needed to happen for you to
get sober and like you're such a
different person now and it sounds like
a much healthier and better person too I
bet your misss feels relieved that this
has all happened yeah it crazy because
for 10 like we've been together 10 years
for 9 years it felt like for like 8 and
a half years we didn't know if we were
meant to be together cuz we were arguing
and everything like that and she's so
happy you know and I'll be honest with
you it's it is it's it's difficult
looking back but it serves as like a it
does serve as like a a bit of a you know
I've showcased it all the last year to
my audience you know and I've split my
Audience by you know talking about
sobriety and being very open about what
I thought addiction was and what it
actually is and all of this stuff and
and the things I done wrong and how to
be a better father and all that and it
has divided my some my audience to a
certain some people don't want to hear
that I built my audience on you know
being wild um but over the last couple
of weeks especially when we found out
that she was pregnant it was extremely
emotional because you know she's genuine
not not because she let me shagger again
obviously but but she's genu she's
genuinely for the first time I truly
believe in the last 10 years she's
genuinely happy like she bounces around
she's she's like like when I first met
her and it's hard because I look like
she'd been dealing with addiction and
also the roller coaster of my career
while her life was on hold yeah um but
you know I get to do a whole pregnancy
soar and become a father and I got two
little babies so it is beautiful and um
I I think you're right it it needed you
know it it needed to happen it and it's
great really yeah yeah yeah I I think
for someone who was as wild as you the
low had to be really really low for you
to like wake up to to the reality of
what was going on so I'm really happy
for you man it's such a great uh sort of
circle to complete in that way I think I
think it serves as a a nice there's a
lot of lads struggling man I've got a
group called men and their emotions on
Facebook it's it's called Uh mates men
and their emotions we unfortunately like
it's just blown up I say unfortunately
because it just shows how much Pain's on
there it's got 50,000 Lads in in it and
the concept for me was really simple cuz
so many Lads were reaching out to me you
know that was suicidal or and I just
didn't feel qualified you know I looked
at my [__] therapy sessions and that
I was like but I created this group
where Lads can they can write in there
cuz I believe that a massive part of the
problem is men need men right yeah I I
believe that men need men not just like
to to be held accountable um to vent you
know cuz we only really are used to
venting with drinking drugs
know something that boing me group is
going well hold on a second your M
shouldn't put up with that yeah you know
when you hear it from another man it's
[__] different you know when your m
is going why should I put up with this
when another man says she old in a
second that is an amazing woman mate she
shouldn't put up with that [__] and
stuff like I had from my boxing coach
the first time I tried to get sober how
are you going to feel when another man's
bringing up your kids cuz I'll be honest
with you Dan I don't think you'll be to
handle it and you kill yourself and I
was like cried on the way home you know
boxing and was like I I need to get
sober and um it's that it's that's what
we're we're men are lacking so this
group just gives men the opportunity to
post their problems and strangers chip
in and um it's a bit like Jeremy Cole
you know you watch Jeremy you don't feel
so [__] about yourself you know what I
mean it's a bit like that you know even
if you're just watching you know other
people are going through it you
know men we need friendship we need it
and as you get older you know everybody
goes their separate ways and they have
their careers and their families but I
think that's something that men really
need we really need other men and we
need that bonding experience where we
can have a chat where we can vent
because one of the things I find
worrying about male emotion is and I
look at I look at myself in this is that
is really only anger and then when
everything gets too much with me it's
tears it just goes and that's not a
healthy way to be yeah I think when you
see a man lashing out and being
aggressive he's crying yeah you you know
what I mean he hasn't been taught how to
cry like all I used to look at all this
well-being stuff you know and I when
people used to say I used to hate it
when people I used to think it was an
upper class thing when people would say
that they're going I'm finding myself
I'm going to find I'm like what the [__]
do you mean you're right there but the
truth is is men um especially if they
haven't had a father figure which a lot
of us haven't but men um are expected
you know
stiff up a li man up don't worry go and
graft have a beer you know you'll be all
right as long as you're making money as
long as you're making money and you're
shagging or whatever you'll be all right
they don't know how to express
themselves at all and the key to it is
talking right and through my sobriety I
haven't being able to shut up about you
know you see my podcast I mean I'm
crying on my podcast all the time you
know when I go back to stuff that I've
done wrong personally myself I really
try and hone in on that emotion and I
let it out and um when you see men like
smashing things up or going wild or
fighting that's them crying but they
haven't learned yeah how to cry you know
what I mean yeah and it's because we
only have access it's like if you think
about it like a piano and your emotions
are all all the keys we only have access
to a couple of keys so if you've only
can play one key you're going to play
one key really hard which is the anger
the rage the the lashing out yeah big
one for me is being trolls trolls really
used to I don't know why they used to
and I'm reading this book at a moment
called ego the enemy and um I'm learning
so much about how like how I view myself
you know like I thought I just looked at
myself as a creative comedian you know
and I come up with these characters and
the comedy and I think oh you're a
little bit of a comedy genius but it
turns out that actually through the
followers and you know the money and the
whatever that I kind of fell into this
weird thing of thinking no I'm actually
really special so when a troll would say
something to me I'd be like how dare you
you know how dare they now that I'm
working on my ego just realizing look
you're just a [__] normal comedian
that's a little bit more creative that's
had a couple of breaks that graphs hard
I can be like well yeah whatever you're
saying mate it's like whatever it might
be you know so I'm working on that and I
think for us men that's a massive part
of mental health problems because we all
have this like idea in our minds that we
are supposed to be this and if we're not
that then we're not enough do you know
what I mean yeah yeah I think that's
really important especially in the
modern world where I think um I mean
this is blunt put but I do think it's
true there's a lot of women telling men
how they're supposed to be and I'm like
with all possible respect you don't know
what you're talking about yeah yeah you
know um so in that world I think it's
increasingly important for guys to be
talking for to be talking to each other
you know and also for male role models
because and you see this with like the
Andrew Tates of the world and whatever
you're going I don't think that's a good
role model for men at all but I also
think the fact he is a symptom of the
problem
he's not the people like all these
journalists want to make it out like
Andrew Tate is the problem Andrew Tate
is not the problem it's the fact that
men would listen to someone like Andrew
Tay that's telling you what the problem
is and that means these men do not have
good role models in their lives who can
go no no this is actually how you do
this yeah Andrew T is such a conundrum
isn't it because you know me and my wife
I know Andrew actually I've met I've met
him I met him in a in a really strange
way back in the day because on Twitter
we had a bit of a conflict because he
was he was talking about um you know
mental health not being a real thing and
depression and that and I I actually
quoted one of his tweets and started
going in on him and then clicked on his
profile this was before he was massive I
had more followers than him at the time
and I clicked on his profile and then
saw that he was like a [__]
kickboxing champion and I was like all
right mate let's let's wind it in and
then I bumped into him randomly at an
event with him and his brother walking
down and they were he was like remember
me and I was like and they both went ah
so he had like a laugh and a joke with
me and um in person I thought he was
great but my wife obviously she's very
much like I don't like his stuff and and
I'm like but he speaks some sense right
that is the problem because mixed in
with everything that whatever he does
and all of that there's messages in what
he says that men resonate with because
there's no one else talking about it and
the only other thing that we we get to
see and I swear to God I've I've always
been terrified of even talking about how
narcissistic women can be and how and
how sort of how how it looks what it
looks like what the landscape of social
media and the world looks like from a
man it's like you're almost terrified to
be a man you know what I mean and and
it's constant negativity you're this
you're that you're this you should do
this and if you don't do this it's you
know you're not it's not just social
media it's the media it's movies it's
advertising it's it's the entire kind of
uh content space is filled with these
messages of like you're not allowed to
be a man the way that a man needs to be
to be actually fulfilled and happy and
have purpose and meaning and whatever
which is what Andrew T is happening into
I I have literally while I don't like a
lot of the things that he says and I
have no issue with Andrew Tate because
people wouldn't be listening to Andrew
Tate if there wasn't the problem in the
first place he's just fulfilling a need
that's there um and if there were
healthier role models and if me there
were and this is why Jordan Peterson
became so big because he was the first
person that came along and actually said
to men for like a decade oh my God yeah
it's okay to be a man it's okay to be a
man yeah and and not just that
like you you do not know the joy and
like the the the happiness I was filled
with where I when I saw him arguing with
journalists that I'd seen put me down
and go well hold on a second I didn't
actually say that and and and and like
saying to them sorry are you you know
you angry about something and and then
you know and I watched that and I was
like mate I wish that I was articulate
enough or intelligent enough to or back
then had the foresight to to you know or
the patience or the confidence to say
well actually guys There's No Malice in
anything I said and the only people that
are offended by what I said are because
of the the way that you've twisted it
and given it to them because no one at
my [__] show complained about a thing
do you know what I mean so you know
hopefully there'll be they'll be more
it's difficult to how many successful
male men out there don't get attacked as
well do you know what I mean it's very
difficult to be successful it's men and
women the moment you're successful you
get attacked that's how it is yeah yeah
it yeah I I sometimes I've got to hold
myself back because it was a lot of
female journalists it was a lot of you
know what I thought was toxic feminism
and you know like I handled the way that
I was you know and I I went on like a PR
thing for a little while as well where
I'd go and sit down and do interviews
with a lot of journalists and be like
yeah I get it you know I want to learn
more you know I even sat and said I want
to learn more about sexism I want to
learn more about this culture you're
talking about and then they would simply
go Dapper thinks we should educ him not
to rape and stuff like and then I just I
just thought after that I just thought
you know what yeah [__] off then and I
I'll you know it's very hard you know
what a lot of women are fed up with this
[__] as well I say this all the time
like my wife hates all this stuff she's
completely not into any of this she
doesn't she's just interested in you
know being a mother and doing the stuff
that she does within her own life and
whatever but she see everyone sees this
and a lot of women see the the same
toxic narratives being pushed because
women want men too women want men to be
men too but what you have is a small
sliver of the kind of content creating
class who are pushing these messages
because it fits with their [__]
narrative about you know toxic
masculinity whatever which is why it's
really great to hear your journey from
what happened to where you are now I'm
just really happy for you man it's it's
awesome I really love it and it's been
great having you on the show as you know
the last question we always ask is
what's the one thing that we're not to
talking about as a society that we
should be before we go to our locals and
ask you a bunch of questions from our
supporters um why I think I think um the
fact that mental health and well-being
isn't implemented into our children um
at school uh I think I think that's
something that through through my
struggles because I always knew that it
wasn't good to drink and it wasn't good
to do drugs but I never really knew why
uh and you know and also I've got a tool
box now of things that I use very much
like yourself uh if if if I'm having a
bad day or if I can see my mind is going
in the wrong direction but that is that
that's a toolbox that I've had to put
together and create after years and
years of self-abuse and and and and
Trauma and you know really that toolbox
has been created halfway through my life
you know luckily before my you know I
can pass on to my kids so I think that
we need to talk more about creating them
toolbox for kids while they're at school
well here's something I might disagree
with you on actually because my worry
with what's happening in schools is I
mean they're being taught all kinds of
crazy [__] right now and I worry that
mental health becomes this thing about
how there's 53 genders and whatever I
actually think you hid the nail on the
head when you said pass it on to your
kids yeah maybe that's better I I think
ultimately this is [__] the parents are
going to have to teach their kids yeah
uh I think there's actually a third way
like a mate of mine who's a teacher
who's implemented stoicism to teaching
to Primary School Kids which is I think
a really good way of doing it which is
teaching you you know how to be stoic
how to not let your in your emotions
take you away yeah it's just my worry
with the educational system is all of
this gets perverted corrupted and it all
ends up being you know yeah that's also
true that is that is why so the the
people that are look ultimately the best
thing that I think you can do for your
kids is teach them yourself the things
that that you have learned and tell them
the stories of your own life and really
be honest about it cuz that will grab
them I know that I've had you know
people in my family do that with me and
that's been how I've learned a lot of
stuff but I had to discover a lot of
stuff for myself and maybe that's also
part of the journey man yeah it's a
tough one because you're right yeah but
yeah you're right you're right but
generally people learning more about the
toolbox of how to manage your emotions
just yeah H having them conversations
with your children H definitely you know
now that you've said that the more you
think about it cuz my parents my
parents taught me about right and wrong
but didn't teach me about how to deal
with my emotions yeah you know what I
mean but also they were a product of
their time ex people didn't talk about
it back then people didn't have emotions
back then M it was it was the
1960s especially men yeah exactly so and
I think you know sometimes you know I'm
a guilty of this where we go I my
parents didn't teach me this didn't
teach me that and it was like but
they're a product of their time yeah
they didn't know what they didn't they
didn't know exactly what they didn't
know we're a product of our time and so
on and so forth so a big part of this is
also forgiveness forgiving the people
who have wronged you forgiving the
people who when you when you when you
were brought up made mistakes made
errors they were human beings as well
and they did their best yeah I certainly
don't agree with um you know I think the
Americans are big for it you know when
it when it's you know they do their they
do their their what their therapy and
it's all their parents' fault you know
it can't it's you know
yeah it's all right 18 when you get to
41 and you're blaming Mom and Dad it's a
little a
line I will say this I don't think it's
possible to be truly happy until you've
forgiven your parents and and become
grateful to them yeah and 100% And I
think one thing I'll definitely finish
this conversation on is that um the one
of the biggest causes of addiction and
uh mental health problems especially
self-loathing and stuff like that is is
down to our what our narrative is about
ourselves how we feel about ourselves
and a massive massive
part is down to the deals that you make
with yourself you know if you like if I
go to my boxing gym and my my trainer
isn't there and that happens a couple of
times I think that guy's a knobbed and I
don't want to be around him and it's the
same for ourselves if we say I want to
get fit I want to stop drinking I want
to and you stop keeping the deals with
yourself The Narrative is that you're
you're worthless so not keeping them
deals pretty beautiful head on over to
locals where we ask Dan your
questions
do you believe that the current
Advocates of wokeness will be able to
retain their credibility after in its
inevitable demise and do they personally
feel cap do you personally feel capable
of forgiving
them